nicely done
i'll be honest i don't feel like he's
particularly hard i don't feel like he's
particularly hard i don't feel like he's
particularly hard
weak foe ahead i don't know if i believe
you boss fight time baby let's go all
right let's go dude
all right so first first attempt
probably going to be a lot of figuring
things out
kind of weak to magic
looks like
i think we're gonna be able to get him
below half just with our magic
oh okay he does try something different
now
oh i wasn't expecting that that was new
dang we're doing so good too
all right so now i'm wondering if it's
better to play him up close first try to
get him down to about half health
and i just i need a shield that does
100
oh come on
oh i didn't think he was gonna do that
that time
i'll be honest i don't feel like he's
particularly hard i don't feel like he's
particularly hard i don't feel like he's
particularly hard
no
oh
oh
i didn't know you could cast it so
quickly i'm dead though
oh i thought i was dead
okay i'm dead there yeah i really don't
feel like his attack patterns it's not
that difficult i'm just really not doing
much damage which could mean i think i'm
fine where i'm at
oh i'm stuck on the are you serious
yeah i i knew
oh he's got a sword too okay here we go
i'm stuck again
man his attacks like see i need to stay
close to him
no
no
no i dodged away
gotta dodge to him you gotta dodge to
him retro come on
no
no
oh my goodness
yikes
no
miss that dodge
missed oh my god
stop crouching
stop crouching
we're out of everything
all right we gotta go sword
no
no
oh that was the one
oh not good
oh
oh no
out of everything
come on yeah i'm this is a terrible run
right here
just kill me just end it just end it
yeah i knew that was gonna be a bad
dodge
okay all right all right oh i'm out
i'm dead this is it
the sword the sword throws me off
oh i always stuck that when i always
dodged that one
no
oh my gosh get out of here
get out of here can't move
no
no no
i almost feel like in this second phase
a little bit
like you you have to keep your distance
from him a little at times
jump away please
no
no
i see
i can't even move right there
how does he still have so much health
how does he still have so much else i
felt like i was doing so good that time
oh i hate this one
i hate the one with the sword man
like where am i i'm all the way backed
up right against the door oh
oh my god
wow well it was working out
and then he pulls out the sword
what
what was that attack
what
in the world was that and wow what a hit
that was
yep okay goodbye
okay i tried to dodge that see if you
hang around
what i can't move i'm stuck on the rocks
yeah i'm just
another new thing
and then he's going oh my goodness
then he goes with the freaking sword
what it did not roll
all right honestly guys like i'm gonna
try one more time and if i don't get it
i'm gonna go and just try to level up a
few things
yep my favorite i i
i have no idea what to do when the gold
when that gold sword comes out
when you're close and that gold sword
comes out i'm just like yeah i got
nothing
all right let's go back up here let's
heal up
let's level up level up our intelligence
one more time so it's gonna do a little
bit more damage on the guy
but i gotta beat him i gotta beat him
all right let's take the intelligence up
it's been 1 45 runes yes we will
all right so we've done a couple of
things we've gotten uh this armor it's
going to make us a little bit stronger
so we can take a little bit more in
terms of hits from him
we've upgraded our magic power
so it's going to hit a little bit harder
and we've also upped our vigor so we
have a few more hit points nothing crazy
right
no that was like a perfect run
this guy is such a punk dude oh my gosh
he's such a punk
oh wow
okay
oh my gosh
okay yeah pretended to happen
yikes
i hate that move i don't know how to
block it i don't know what to do when he
does that
[Music]
i blame the camera
i blame the camera oh my gosh man
like
that is so
on the camera right there
are you kidding me guys oh i had that i
had that i had that i had that
are you kidding me right now
like the camera has not looked like that
this entire
entire
boss fight against this guy
and now of course i missed my first
magic attack
and now i'm just mad
warrior blood must
oh i'm out
so
what the heck was that
oh
my gosh
get away from this guy
oh i just need a little more magic and i
can take him
[Music]
oh my gosh dude
arrows anything like
firebomb something to throw at him
get away
no like see dude why are you crouching
right there
[Music]
let's go
oh my gosh
oh my goodness dude
look how much health i had one hit i'm
done one hit
it's over
wow